americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 68
and welcome to hannity yup 68 long days
our americans fellow americans their
families our allies thousands of green
card holders all trapped behind the
enemy lines of the taliban abandoned by
your president joe biden according to
multiple reports one young woman
beheaded by the taliban why because she
once played for the afghan national
volleyball team as we speak all female
athletes in the country they're being
hunted down by the taliban female
athletes are not allowed to exist in the
new islamic emirates of afghanistan oh
the one that joe and jen sake say are so
business-like and professional all
according to joe right now the people
that you are taking off the terror watch
list
joe biden is now allowing former taliban
leaders
taking them off the watch list and
allowing them to come to america does he
think they've changed do we have any
indication they may have changed i doubt
they changed and of course biden has
simply moved on or in his words he's
turned the page after all he has more
important things to worry about like
reminiscing about his long train rides
to delaware very important matters take
a look
angelo negri was from remember ranch
ange came up to me one day when i was
when they just had announced that i had
flown uh one million some x number of
miles on air force aircraft
and ange comes up and i'm getting in the
car and he goes joey baby what do you
and i thought the secret service was
going to shoot him i said no no no no
he's good it's good
true story you know how many miles you
did amtrak and i said no angel i don't
have any idea pal he said let me tell
you we were at the retirement dinner
and he said we added it up you averaged
100 i think it says 21 days a year
121 days a year 36 years plus as vice
president boom boom you have traveled
over 2 million miles joe i don't hear
any more about the air force
well i talk about afghanistan uh and the
americans he abandoned or his disaster
at the border or begging opec for energy
uh or the disaster known as the biden
economy now that bizarre that rambling
story is not even true according to
multiple media outlets and fact checkers
but that never stops joe biden from
impeding one lie after another in this
case on five separate occasions and even
worse apparently joe biden now believes
he was vice president of the united
states for get this 36 years
a lot of the folks in amtrak became my
family not a joke
i'd ride every day i i commuted every
single day for 36 years as
president vice president united states
after my wife and daughter were killed i
went home to see my family never stopped
going doing that
36 years as vice president okay i think
it's pretty clear to everyone watching
joe biden is not well
this man should not be our president he
is not mentally cognitively strong
enough and not fit to serve and by the
way he also has blood on his hands as a
result of his decision in afghanistan
something he said he wouldn't do and now
because of biden's obvious decline his
radical base they're calling all the
shots their new green deal socialism is
destroying the economy his policy on
energy is killing everybody everybody's
paying more for every item we buy look
at this tonight's american labor
shortage is so bad dominos can't find
drivers to deliver its pizzas grocery
store shelves yeah they're going
completely empty and that's all across
the country we have cargo ships that
have been anchored off the coast of
california now for more time than it
took them to cross the pacific ocean
your christmas presents probably are not
going to arrive in time for christmas
and you're going to have to explain to
your kids why santa was being so mean
this year inflation is at a 30-year high
even cnbc is forecasting this looming
recession trillions of dollars in this
new build back better new green deal
socialism spending that will only
exacerbate all of these very serious
problems then to make matters worse well
joe's about to fire thousands of
teachers and nurses and
emergency medical professionals and cops
and soldiers and firefighters because of
his rigid vaccine mandate that will only
exacerbate every problem in the economy
we already have in a major way and
remember biden and other top democrats
they once vowed not to import or support
any kind of vaccine requirement you want
to know where vaccine hesitancy comes
from them because they change their mind
the cdc website changes constantly the
nih flip flop fauchi joe biden all of it
they literally have created an
environment where nobody believes
anything they say this might bring back
memories
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory but
perhaps the federal government should
step in and issue mandates and if not
are you putting the needs of
unvaccinated people ahead of the needs
of vaccinated people well i think the
question here one that's not the role of
the federal government
that is the role that institutions
private sector entities
and others may take that certainly is
appropriate also local communities are
going to take steps they need to take i
don't think you'll ever see a mandating
of vaccine particularly for the general
public
we cannot require that's not something
that we can do oh all of a sudden i
guess they can do it is it just to score
political points or divide the country
for political gain
why is there no other option like many
states and localities have adopted now
whether democrats like it or not look
the debate of vax don't vacs you know
what we've had that debate and for
whatever reason i don't know millions of
americans are willing to lose their job
lose their benefits abandon their
retirement because that's how strongly
they believe in their position many of
these people have rare conditions that
forbids them from getting the vaccine
others have natural immunity and they
believe the science of natural immunity
like for example this case we're all
watching in israel it's going to be
peer-reviewed 800 000 people close to it
and it seems natural immunity is better
than the vaccine time will tell let's
follow the science the debate for them
though for many people is over their
minds are made up they're willing to
lose it all and they're locked in that
will tank our economy we will suffer
even more and why in order to vilify
those americans
that will not make us any safer or more
secure
it's not going to end covert 19. it's
not going to stop the spread but
democrats they don't seem to care about
it how about a simple option like okay
we don't want you to lose your pension
we don't want you to lose your job we
don't want to be short staffed how about
you take a test once a week or twice a
week or whatever by the way why don't
they ever mention monoclonal antibodies
or other treatments whether you have a
breakthrough case of covid or you're
unvaccinated it seems to be working
wonders because joe biden now didn't for
the first time actually mentioned it
because it was so successfully used by
ron desantis in florida they definitely
don't care seemingly about the economy
they made that clear yesterday in
response to the current economic crisis
and opposition to the new green deal
socialism built back better
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
complained that republicans are just
upset about a changing country i think
they are upset about a changing country
i think they are upset about the fact
that we cannot build
or or have or that they cannot really
have
majority you know they cannot be elected
with a majority with just
a very narrow
homogenous
classist
base
and they are scared and they are angry
and they are doing absolutely everything
possible to ensure
that we
disenfranchise
the very people and communities that
have the power of changing this country
for the better i think a lot of people
are upset at the estate of the economy a
lot of americans upset that we abandoned
americans behind enemy lines a lot of
americans are upset at the disaster at
the border a lot of americans are upset
that illegal immigrants get preferential
treatment no cova testing no vaccine
mandates for them i think most americans
are really upset it costs so much more
to fill up their gas tank and heat and
cool their home and of course the rising
grocery bills and empty shelves and
virtually nobody in the media mob is
blaming joe biden even though he
deserves it and he reduced artificially
america's oil and gas supply and in the
meantime demand remain constant that
means the price goes way up and you know
what it's gone way up and he's paying
americans not to work we have record
level spending causing inflation to
skyrocket now by the way hawking a
multi-trillion dollar socialist spending
bill basically stealing from your kids
your grandkids guess what that does to
inflation that'll make it worse the mob
in the media they're not angry about any
of that instead they're mad that joe
biden's messaging isn't more on point
take a look
so what is going on with you why are you
so bad at politicking why are you so bad
at politics democrats
when you have the winning message
when you have the senate
and you have the congress and you have
the white house and you can't win with a
winning message something is wrong
democrats get your butts in gear and get
passionate about saving this damn
country you're not doing it you're weak
you are weak you are weak i'd take a
little disagreement with that winning
message thing about socialism but anyway
forget the horrible economic crisis joe
biden needs to sell it better really
well we i guess the greedy spoiled
people of america i guess we all just
need to lower our expectations settle
for less tell your kids at christmas
that santa is mad at you and it's not
going to be the same this year we need
to stop complaining sit back enjoy
another dark winter under joe biden and
anthony fauci